Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 19th,
2018 what's going on?
How,
why is that loud enough with my ears shot?
Um,
what's going on?
I'm really,
I'm super late.
I apologize.
I apologize to anybody.
I may have offended a Rolex Americans,
um,
anybody indigenous to the clock world,
you know.
Oh,
sorry.
Original.
I learned that when I was up in Canada.
They do not want to be called indigenous.
They want to be called the original cog.
The old Geezer.
This shit.
That's what they want to be called pre provinces.
You white motherfuckers.
I believe that's what they said.
Except they said it with a drum.
Now they didn't do they burn the,
the originals up in Canada that they communicate through drums too.
You know,
it's so funny.
Once white people got their hands on it,
all of a sudden all communication,
just start
with that instrument.
Um,
well that's because we invented the fucking phone.
You dumb fuck eight.
Keep it fucking classy there.
I'm
sorry.
I'm in a fucked up mood.
I flew back from Toronto late last night.
I was in Kitchener or Kitchener.
I have no idea.
Came up with a great fucking touristy tee shirt for those people out there.
All right.
If he can't stand the heat,
get out of the Kitchener.
Huh?
They need something.
They need some swagger out there because everybody was giving me shit.
Why you flood plain old [inaudible].
There we go.
First of all,
I was just in Toronto.
And then secondly,
those people like entertainment too.
But now they got to drive an hour and a half all the way in.
They got to pay for parking.
If they're going to booze now they've got to get a room and all of a sudden
becomes this big fucking deal.
So I like going to places like Kitchener and uh,
Hamilton neck casino on the other side of Detroit.
And then there was that other one,
that Casino Rama,
that Gig where I left the rental car.
I ever tell you guys said fucking story.
I left a rental car there,
man.
Um,
we went out,
we did the show.
I'm not naming any names in this one.
Okay.
Me and some friends of mine.
Not My usual friends.
These friends were readers,
these were big readers and they never predicted anything.
Okay.
Um,
they didn't predict someone was going to be a hall of Famer after one at bat.
It was not anybody like that.
Wink,
wink,
nudge,
nudge.
Anyways,
so we were up there at Casino Rama and um,
we drove up from someplace else.
I can't remember,
we'd done a couple of gigs out there and uh,
like march madness was going on or some sort of ladies hockey for some metal
assumption.
I can't remember what.
And we went out,
did the show and we went out and got fucking hammered,
hammered knowing that we had an early flight and then I had her turn this rental
car.
So we keep looking at the watch guys.
You know,
we kinda gotta be up at 5:00 AM it's,
it's midnight.
That's five hours sleep.
One more,
one more bubble Nexia.
We got it.
And I swear to God and like three in the fricking morning and I am hammered that
I mentioned I was drunk,
I was fucking hammered.
So wake up like two hours later,
you know,
with a bunch of snacks opened from the fucking hotel bar.
One of those nights,
you know,
trying to get down like another whiskey.
I maybe got one swig out of it,
like Denzel in that movie where he fucking flies the plane upside down.
He some overcome losing his rear stabilizer
and the first guy ever in the history of aviation.
Um,
and then I uh,
you know,
open can of Pringles and a kit Kat.
I think so.
I stumbled downstairs.
All right.
We're,
you know,
and we get in the fucking car,
right?
I'm still fucking hammered.
I'm like,
guys,
I'm too fucking drunk to drive.
And they're like,
dude,
the airports right down the street,
this is how every faith fatal drinking and driving story happens.
It's right down the street.
So we look at our fucking gps cause was still,
we still on the hotels fucking thing there and we were trying to memorize it
because none of us got a plan when we were up there.
Well,
wouldn't,
you know,
we leave the hotel's fucking airspace and we can't figure out where we're going.
It's,
it's fucking low visibility.
It's still pitch black out.
And now we have no map.
I don't know where I'm at and we're all fucking hammered.
And I was just like,
dude,
I can't do this.
So we literally got like a fucking quarter mile down the street,
turned back around,
go back to the hotel and we say,
listen to,
cause we Kinda,
you know,
hit it off with the guy behind the fucking,
uh,
the counter that can do as favor.
You know,
what can you,
is there any way you can return this rental car?
And the guy goes,
no problem,
no problem.
We'll call you a cab.
I got my buddy,
he'll come down,
he'll return the fucking thing,
blah,
blah.
No problem.
So now we're sweating it,
right?
But it turns out that the pilots and shit are also waiting for a car and we were
on their flight or whatever,
somehow,
so African,
it's all fucking foggy.
So we ended up getting there.
We make the flight back
laughing our asses off.
Hey,
we did it.
You know what a good shit that guy returns the fucking car.
What an awesome guy.
Right.
And I,
I passed out on the plane and I wake up in la like nothing ever happened.
So,
um,
I fucking,
uh,
maybe like three weeks later I get this phone call from the rental company
and they will like,
yeah,
Mr Raw,
you ever going to return that rental car?
I told this story wrong.
I shouldn't told you that I left it to the hotel guy.
I had completely forgot.
I even,
I,
that's how drunk I was.
I didn't even remember that part where I said that I was gonna fucking that.
I told the guy at the hotel and I was like,
yeah,
it returned.
It returned like three weeks ago and at this point I've done like three mile
road gigs,
so I don't even remember it.
And I'm like,
yeah,
it did.
How did you get my number?
You keep my number.
I was all about me.
So they start badgering me in my fucking world and I'm just like,
you know,
I have to like the fourth or fifth phone call.
I was like,
listen,
stop calling me.
I returned the rental car.
Stop calling me on my cell phone.
I'm at work and level done.
Then just one time,
I don't know what happened,
like the sixth time they called me,
something just clicked.
I was like,
wait a minute.
We sent that gig where I was hammered
and there will clouds on the ground and I,
the guy behind the counter said he was going to,
or some people called fog,
we're going to fucking return the rental car.
Oh fuck.
So I had to call after yelling at these people,
I to call him and be like,
Yo,
listen,
I'm the guy you called like six times ago.
Uh,
I got really drunk and uh,
try to drive,
but I couldn't.
The guide,
the hotel Shah,
he was kind of thinking,
dude ended up fucking going down to the car,
was still sitting there.
I had to pay a month rental on that thing.
I can't even fucking tell you how much money that cost me.
Um,
but whatever.
That's not the big news.
The big news as announced by Barstool sports.
Remember I was telling you rough and rowdy was going to be a juggernaut and I
would just blah,
blah,
blah.
That and I thought it was just the greatest frigging idea ever.
It's literally,
it's like American idol meets the UFC.
All those people that think they can fucking sing and want to prove it and then
look what happened.
Some of them come out of there and they win grammys.
So who knows?
Maybe one of these people when there's rough and rowdy thing could actually
someday get in the UFC house,
right?
And then,
then next thing you know,
fucking a,
he's all,
he's on one of those pay per views.
But until then they were at the bar stool sports,
a rough and rowdy number tree trois.
And uh,
I'm actually going to be ringside thrown in some jokes.
You guys got to get this man,
you have to get this fucking paper view.
I'm telling you,
I'm going to be making fun of people.
I'm going to be making fun of myself.
It's uh,
it's $15 and 99 cents to watch regular people beat the shit out of each other.
You know what I mean?
It's the greatest thing,
greatest singer of all time.
This is like,
there's certain things you just see coming,
you like,
this is gonna be fucking huge.
I the second I saw this,
it's like I'm going to watch every fucking one of these things and I'm,
I don't know,
it was just talking positively about it.
And then a bar stool reached out to the email and they're like,
you want to do this?
So it's just like a,
yeah.
Fuck yeah,
absolutely.
So I'm going to be there.
So tuned in.
Um,
let me see if I can get you the date here.
I'm so fucking excited about this.
I can't even tell you.
Um,
when the hell is it going to be,
I'm the worst kid.
Does anybody promote shit worse than me?
I know that it's going to be in Charlotte,
North Carolina.
April 13th.
It's going to be April 13th.
Charlotte,
North Carolina,
formal hometown of the nature.
Boy,
ric flair.
I mean,
everything's just,
this is serendipity.
It's all fucking lining up.
I can't wait.
Um,
so please,
uh,
you and your friends,
or to the God damn fight,
get yourself some beers and who knows,
maybe a watch or get inspired and the next time you'll be on it,
that's just that easy.
Would you ever want to be on TV?
Try to knock somebody out.
Finally,
there's a vehicle for you.
So anyways,
uh,
why are you so late today,
bill?
Well,
I had a busy day.
I,
why?
I flew back from Toronto after our two awesome shows in Kitchener.
Uh,
they're definitely,
they're on,
they're on the toilets now.
I,
they have such awesome people there and a great venue and a,
so I flew back late at night cause I wanted to be,
you know,
get home late at night.
So when my daughter woke up the next day,
I was going to be there.
You know what I mean?
Because of what I do,
you know,
so I missed some days sometimes,
so like literally the ups guy comes walking up to walk and she's pointing
going.dot,
dot,
dot.
Like,
I can't handle that.
I have too much fucking guilt over it.
All right.
Um,
however,
I do have to provide for my family.
So anyways,
I,
um,
I hung with my daughter in the morning and then I had this meeting from 10 to
12.
And then when I came back,
my wife told me that she was going to take our daughter to go see the Easter
bunny.
And I was like,
well,
I don't want to miss that.
So I went over there and,
uh,
you know,
last year she was fine because she was only like,
four or five months old.
And this year she's like,
you know,
coming up on a year and a half or whatever.
And uh,
you know,
I just felt this vibe.
I was just,
she was looking at the fucking person in this outfit and I'm just looking at it
like,
I dunno about this one,
right?
So we're trying to be like,
hey,
and the bunnies fucking waving at her and shit.
And I went up and I'm shaking the rabbits hand and stuff like,
see,
it's safe.
It's not cutting my head off.
And she's just looking at the rabbit,
like,
I dunno about this man.
She's like dead dude and platoon.
I got a bad feel above this man.
So we bring her up there and immediately like I go to kind of hand it to the,
to the fucking dude in the bunny suit and I just feel her just grab two handfuls
of my t shirt.
I'm like,
oh no.
And then I was like,
she started screaming and then I handed it to my wife.
My wife ended up happened to sit down with her with the rabbit.
She's totally crying,
totally freaked out and all that.
And the whole time I'm just sitting there going,
why do we do this to kids?
Why am I doing this in a freaking this kid out with a fucking person in a
Goddamn bunny suit?
It makes no sense to the kid.
And at the end,
at the end of all of this horse shit,
it's a fucking lie doll thing is a fucking lie.
And then one day you got to turn around and tell your kid it's not real
and it's just as selfish adult thing because you love your kids so much.
You wanted to see,
get excited.
You know when you grew up and you saw how mean and cold hearted the world is,
you just want to see him fucking believe in something.
And then just early on you just break the trust by telling them that as he's
fucking people that come by.
Some of them are animals in Italy.
I mean,
some of them are fairies and all of this shit.
Um,
but then what do you do?
Do you tell your kid that,
that,
that they don't exist and then they go to school to come to school like some
grizzled fucking vet.
And let me tell you some kids,
it's all bullshit,
right?
Just to tell it all these kids that the bunny does it exist in Santa Claus
doesn't exist to that.
Everybody's getting fucking mad at your kid.
It's a great life lesson actually for your kid.
That's what happens when you tell the truth.
Oh,
he's on his fucking stuck right now.
Okay.
Yeah.
If you ever want to get yelled at that,
there you go.
Send your kid to school with the truth about Santa Claus and the Easter Bunny.
And you just sit,
say your kid,
just say,
listen,
everybody talks about reading to your kid,
trying to give them a headstart and all that.
Why don't you fucking give them a headstart and not fucking tell them about all
that shit?
What am I?
Relatives did that with one of my nephews,
you know,
and the kid grew up fine.
They just sat it down like,
yeah,
listen,
it's all bullshit.
You know?
I remember when I found out my older brother told me and um,
he felt betrayed and when he told me I felt like an adult,
I was like,
no ways.
Didn't ain't no thanks for the heads up.
Then I sat there and kept my mouth shut like an old school mobster.
I never told my,
my other brothers never said Shit.
I just sat there.
Oh yeah,
he's coming right down the fucking chimney.
Then I sit there laughing,
listen to my younger brother's telling me stories.
I saw his sleigh go right off the roof of digits you lying piece of Shit,
you know,
and let me know.
Let me know who they really were.
I learned who I could trust in my family.
Having that insight information.
I think that's why they're trying to get that Alexa and everybody's house so
then they can tell you know who they can trust and who they can't trust and not
really for a good reason either.
You know,
there is corrupt as I am,
except they're running shit.
I have no idea what I'm talking about right now.
Um,
I lied to you guys earlier.
I didn't have a meeting from 10 to 12.
What I did was I went out and I flew out to camera Rio and then down the coast
along Malibu.
I,
one of the most perfect fucking days ever while the whales are migrating.
Okay.
I should have literally had like fucking Yoga,
Yoga music playing in my fucking,
uh,
headset.
It was,
it was fucking unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
Uh,
I dunno,
whatever.
Sorry.
I skate.
You got me.
I apologize.
And we were supposed to take our kid.
I'm to be totally honest with you guys,
and I'm supposed to take the kids to see these two bony tomorrow and then my
wife's schedule flip flopped around.
And it was more convenient for her to go today.
It was more convenient for us to go tomorrow,
but it's more convenient for her to go today.
So what do you think happened?
You know what happened?
God dammit,
you know exactly what happened.
Oh,
I went to a Toronto Raptors game by the way,
on the Sunday and I went to that Okc game.
That game was like fucking one 32 to one 26 something crazy like that was almost
like an all star game score.
And um,
we had great seats and all of that stuff.
It just was fucking awesome.
Great Fan base to Jesus Christ.
I know you guys love the leafs,
but obviously Toronto is doing great this year,
but uh,
it's a really fun game to watch and um,
that knocked off.
I've seen every professional Canadian fucking team,
a home game of them except for the Goddamn fucking Ottawa senators.
And every time I schedule something to go see one of their games,
something comes up and I can't make it all right the first time.
Unfortunately,
one of my great friends in life passed away and I had to go to the funeral and
all that,
so that's understandable.
All right.
And the second time it was just like,
all right,
I'm flying in two days early.
I'm a dad now.
I'm going to miss 48 hours with my daughter to go to a fucking Ottawa senators
game.
I couldn't justify it,
so I canceled that.
So it's really,
it has nothing to do with Ottawa or their franchise or any of that type of shit.
But,
um,
I believe that they're actually making a new,
a new arena.
Isn't that unbelievable?
It's like what is wrong with the other one?
The other one is totally fine.
That's like the Atlanta Braves moving out of their totally perfectly fine
baseball stadium.
The Atlanta Falcons moving out of their totally perfectly fine fucking dome.
Like what are we doing?
And then they take,
what did you,
what did they do with all of that material?
I want to stay.
Not someone should make a fucking documentary on that when they knocked down a
fucking stadium.
That works fine.
All right.
But the owners,
all you
fucking move them get fat.
Fuck.
I'm sick of seeing cities being held hostage by these fucking crybaby owners,
especially the fucking NFL.
Those fucking assholes.
Such a great game.
Such a crew,
a console that runs it.
How much more fucking money to those assholes need to me need to make before
their pony up for a fucking stadium?
You know what,
without threatening or everybody that they're gonna walk out,
no one full.
Well that most people are like me and they don't read.
They don't have any other passions.
They got nothing else going on in their life.
Knowing full well that if they,
the politicians would be like,
well,
if we let this fucking thing go,
I'm not going to get voted into office.
I'm a Bob craft.
Even though he ponied up money for the,
he was going to a good burger.
Dota condotti kick him and he's dumped fucking loafers.
I love the guy.
I,
there's two things with that happened in the y is a bunch of things that
happened.
My history is a Patriot fan that bugged me.
Bill Parcells telling the team that he was allegedly,
that he was going to,
he wasn't coming back the next year before we played the Green Bay packers.
That's why I've still yet to watch the two bills.
Okay.
Because somebody who was not connected to the football team told me a long time
ago that he did that and I believed it back then.
The way I believed that there was a Santa Clause,
Bill Parcells has the same body type as Santa Claus and the whole thing comes
together and I've just never been able to fucking forgive the guy for something
that I'm not even sure if even.
Okay.
Um,
what else?
What Bob Kraft said he was gonna move into Connecticut.
That was fucking annoying.
Yeah.
We should have let him do it.
Go ahead.
Moving to Connecticut,
moving to the fucking Hartford whalers old building.
See if you could make it work down there.
You can't make anything work in fucking
Connecticut.
The two divided.
Yeah,
so I'm a giant fan.
Some of Patriot fans,
some are dirt poor,
the others are in the Illuminati and there's some Klan members.
I mean,
think about that.
What,
what fucking product can you sell?
Okay.
That's going to appeal to all of those people.
Visit reason why Connecticut lost the whaler state.
They deserved it.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I was actually talking to somebody when I was up in Canada that like what was
great about the fucking hockey divisions when I was a kid,
when I was just the lad,
the Adams Division in the Patrick's division,
if you had a fucking car,
you could literally drive to every road game your team had within its division.
You could probably get there within,
you know,
a couple of hours except for the Quebec Nordiques.
They were way the fuck up there.
Did jumped on a plane.
They will all just like fly to Montreal flight,
a buffalo drive down to Hartford.
Then you had the note was Nordiques to Canadians.
Disablers the way Liz in the Bruins that I'm,
I feel like I'm missing somebody.
Yeah.
Oh,
so long ago.
And then the Patrick Division.
Yeah,
the islanders,
the Rangers,
the devils,
the flyers in the capitals.
All five of them were right there.
And then the road trip,
the long one was Pittsburgh.
All of them right fucking there.
It's like when you used to see like uh,
those,
those things they do on like,
um,
you know,
back in the day when baseball was all on like the east coast essentially and
they would just take trains and there was two teams in Boston,
three teams in New York,
two teams in Philly.
Okay.
The Philadelphia Athletics,
Philadelphia Phillies,
the New York giants,
new,
the Brooklyn Dodgers,
the York Yankees,
formerly the New York Islanders,
formerly the original Baltimore Orioles.
Then the new Baltimore Orioles,
formerly the Saint Louis Browns.
Isn't it amazing?
I know all of this shit and can't do fucking simple math and have no idea what's
going on in the world.
I tried to get a little smarter than on the flight back.
I watched this,
Ken Burns did this whole thing on Vietnam and I watched one that was basically
1970 to 1971.
And what I loved about the documentary is he does not spare the horrors of all
of those people that are just showing the dead bodies and all of that shit and
just like,
mmm.
And just done.
So even handedly,
people who protested the war is won.
Marine was saying like,
I had no problem with people protesting the war.
MMM.
You know,
that's one of the great things about this country and all that type of stuff.
But like those people that will like yelling at him and punching his car and all
that shit,
like they took it too far and I found that really interesting.
You know that you can,
you can,
because we're Kinda,
I feel like we'll live in that right now to the left,
except for some reason they're not protesting this never ending fucking war that
is bankrupting this country.
Uh,
because the people in power geniusly
have sold this one that if you criticize it,
you don't support troops and you're a socialist slash I think you're an isis.
I think that's the way it goes.
If you're even just as an American going like,
hey man,
like I'm down with this country and stuff,
but we're spending $1 billion a month to fight 3,500 people on a jungle gym that
train on a jungle gym.
Like that's just for my business standpoint.
How are we going to continue to sustain this?
If you just even ask that,
that's immediately put into the,
you don't support the troops.
You don't appreciate people fighting for your freedom.
You're a piece of shit.
Uh,
let's ruin your career.
But I feel that they learned that in Vietnam when they've kind of learned that
if they lost the pub,
obviously you'll lose the public support.
Eventually you're going to lose the fucking war.
Um,
and watching these people,
given these speeches so we don't end up at another Vietnam and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then just seeing some of these hippies acting like me to people,
you know,
totally.
Just taking it too far that if somebody even looks like their whole life should
just fucking be destroyed.
You know what I mean?
One person tries to look up a skirt is somebody who's walking up the stairs,
you know,
flight of stairs.
All of a sudden they're doing jello shots with Harvey Weinstein and some
godforsaken place in fucking Arizona.
MMM.
I got a great reality show.
You have Harvey Weinstein and Oj Simpson.
You,
they do a road trip,
right.
And they got,
it's like they got,
they start in La
and they got 36 to get to Atlanta to pick up Paula Dean.
It's like the gumball rally,
you know,
and then she,
cause then she has to go into this big brother house and decide whether or not
she wants to marry dog,
the bounty hunter.
I,
I'm just,
I'm just throwing this out there like this is just a,
and I want to host it and have all the dumb events,
like fucking deck guy and survivor that screams at everybody by wife always
watches survivor.
And I just can't,
it's so fucking,
I get so much anxiety,
you know,
blow Teague,
slowing down.
They need to hurry up.
It's like shut the fuck up.
We know we need the dough.
You explained the game.
You fucking shredded cunt.
Um,
he is in great shape for the Mana,
you know,
he's gotta be sick of it though.
I feel like with that guy every,
I feel like for me,
I feel every fucking season he gets a little more angry
cause at some point,
I mean it's just a finely oiled machine,
but like he sorta has stopped growing as a person because now he's stuck in
groundhog day and it's just like,
and they do it like they've been on the air for like 18 years and they're like
in their 50th season,
like I don't know how many times this poor bastard has to fly to a fucking
island in Fiji and yell at people about,
you know,
how they need to bring a plate of fucking piece,
while walking on some fire,
whatever the fuck it is that that guy does.
Can you add you just,
just sitting there trying to think of another fucking thing that they have to
do.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
It's like that American Ninja was American Ninja Warrior,
which I love that show too,
but it's just like every fight.
I think somebody's got to sit there and think of something that requires even
more grip strength.
I swear to God,
by the time they get in their 50 season,
you're gonna have to fucking be doing pull ups.
You're only holding on with your feet.
The people who trained for that thing,
you know,
you're going to have a,
all generations are going to continue to train for that thing.
I swear to God,
our big toe is going to start sliding down the left side.
He afforded the right side of your foot,
depending on which one you're looking at,
you're going to have thumbs again,
like a fucking ape.
Um,
by the way,
I sell one of the best fucking,
uh,
youtube videos.
You know,
that you'd like those Mashups,
you know,
and a lot of times it's used,
he just picked two songs that are the same temple.
Right.
And you just fucking take the music out of one.
You didn't take the lyrics and Gail,
you slam it together.
I know,
you know,
maybe speed it up a little bit,
but somebody did a rat's round and round with Marvin Gaye.
I heard it through the grapevine,
a check on the Twitter page.
We just posted it or we have it posted by the time this is up.
And uh,
just the way it fits is incredible.
Like it actually sounds right.
Um,
and then I was,
I don't know what the fuck I was just on youtube looking at a bunch of videos
and I somehow found band
with this guy does this impression of Michael MacDonald and he's singing iron
maiden's run to the hills,
but it's totally sung like Michael McDonald and the music that they wrote sounds
like a Michael Mcdonald's song.
Like it doesn't cause I was sitting there listening going,
how the fuck I know this song?
She's like a wild man
cross.
He brought us per beer show,
Bri,
I won't torture you anymore.
Cuellar
took off.
I said he took a Gabe for his old knees.
You got to listen to music underneath it.
It sounds like right around the time when he was working with a steely Dan doing
all that shit.
Um,
whoever would have thought that some bank could sit there and write some blue
eyed soul to fucking iron maid.
All right.
With that,
let me do a little,
uh,
we'll post that one too.
Oh,
probably already have it posted by the time you listen to this,
right?
All right.
Hang on a second.
Um,
all right.
I can do the fucking reads here for the week.
I got to go do the fucking regia for the week.
Uh,
all dollar shave club,
dude,
he attire,
fucking shave and in pain and fucking salient dialysis when it'd be great if
there was a fucking shape club that could do it for just a dollar dollar shave
club.
If the first thing that pops into your fucking Mellon when you hear the name
Dollar Shave Club is an amazing affordable shave,
then here is more information you need to know.
Dollar Shave Club delivers to you everything you need to look,
smell and feel fucking awesome kid shampoo or bodywash fucking toothpaste.
And of course the best raises you'll ever use.
You'll get an amazing high quality shave.
I love when they pads sentences with adjectives.
You're going to know,
why can't you just be an amazing shave or a high quality shape and amazing high
quality super duper shave every morning using dollar Shave Club's executive
fucking ray.
Oh,
you know,
you make it even better.
You use it with it.
Dr Covey's easy shape but
tore to carvers.
Ooze Washer Bordeaux,
put it on yours
and shave your pubes.
Um,
he puts some carvings,
shave Paul around his fucking balls.
God is not soon have a use it.
Use It with Dr Carver's shave butter to help the raise a gently glide across
your skin.
You have to experience it telling you you're going to fill up a little kid.
Another must have experiences.
How Dollar Shave Club delivers everything to you.
That means no more trips to the store,
wandering the aisles,
having tourettes like me hunting for raises,
shampoo and toothpaste kit.
Then having to play a at being a cashier,
scanning the shed bag and your own stuff.
It's a nightmare.
Joined Dollar Shave Club today and for just $5 five bucks is saw buck bucket
with three.
With free shipping,
you'll get the six of six Jesus Christ,
six blade executive raising and a fucking killed somebody with the plus trials,
sizes of shave,
butter,
body cleanser and one wipe Charlies.
Then keep the blades coming for a few more bucks a month.
Get a dollar shave club,
get yours@dollarshaveclub.com that's dollar shave club.com/bar oh look who's
here.
Has stamps.com everybody that you as opposed to serve as an important tool for
any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post
office.
I don't understand why the post office hasn't made an offer to buy stamps.com
and then they just sell their locations tournament to fucking buffalo wild wings
or you rent them out to a corporation.
That's what you do.
And then you still own the property.
That's what the fuck I would do.
Knock down a little bit of the,
uh,
the deficit from fighting these fucking nitwits who don't even have uniforms,
right?
You knock it down a little bit.
Okay?
Make it solving problems like Gallagher.
Um,
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters and packages at your convenience.
24,
seven.
Print postage for any male class,
right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay again.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and printer and the mail carrier picks it up.
Mail everything from postcards to envelopes to pack the packages,
domestic or international.
Create your own stamps.com account in minutes online with no equipment,
no lease and no longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
By the way,
I'm going to be making this sick ass fucking poster for all my big tornadoes
this year.
Uh,
it's going to be a little nod to meet,
turn in half a century old.
Remember what it is?
Sheer Yogurt.
I use,
um,
Yoga.
Huge Sharif for no goddamn leverage.
I use,
I use stamps.com.
Yeah.
Whenever I send out my fucking posters,
I just said that.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
All right.
Oh my God.
Speaking to Vietnam,
speaking,
speaking of Vietnam bike mechanic from Vietnam,
how fucking weird is that?
You know,
who would have thought?
Who would have thunk that?
I would talk about Ken Burns' Vietnam by the way.
I have to watch her.
You get a Ken Burns,
I swear to God,
Ken Burns could do a fucking nine part documentary on clipping your Goddamn
toenails.
And I would watch that.
All right.
Cause he would somehow,
it would be fascinating.
And speaking of,
uh,
amazing television that I watched when I was on the plane,
let me make sure I get the name of the show right.
I watched that new Mike Judge animated show.
Uh,
what is it?
A tour bus from the tour bus have,
has anybody watched that yet?
He basically talks to all these fucking lunatic outlaw country singers.
Okay.
And they tell stories about being out on the road.
I,
I don't,
I yet to go.
I've got to see one with somebody didn't pull a gun on somebody.
Three out of four that I watched the people involved actually shot the other
person.
One got off,
one went to jail.
I'm telling you
the ones I watched,
I watched the Jerry Lee Lewis,
Johnny paycheck.
And then there was this guy Billy Joe something or rather,
and there was one other one that I watched.
They were unbelievable.
And you know,
if Mike Judge is doing,
it's going to be quality.
It may be percent butthead office space.
Uh,
um,
oh,
it's Christ.
What's the name of this?
Okay.
King of the hill.
Jesus Christ.
My brain's going,
I'm going to mush.
Idiocracy which a lot of people didn't see.
Um,
cause it went straight to fucking,
you know,
this is a little too accurate.
Um,
anyways,
I,
I cannot say enough about that show.
I have to watch every fucking one of those.
Um,
and you're really seeing like,
okay,
basically an America that no longer exists.
Half the shit that they do.
It's like,
dude,
there's no fucking way you could do that now.
Just with all the cell phone cameras and all of that and um,
and you just peer into the way.
Okay.
Uh,
I dunno the way men,
an extreme version of an American male thought back in the day,
the way they handled shit.
Fifth thought process.
It just was just,
ah,
I can't even be like,
get on like 20 different fucking levels.
That show is unbelievable.
You have to watch it.
The guys on his team got one of these,
I'll ruin one thing.
This guy is on trial for shooting this guy in the face.
Okay.
And the judge goes,
well,
couldn't you just ran away or walked away saying he didn't have to do it?
Basically.
And the guy looks at the judge,
he's like,
buddy,
I'm from Texas.
We don't run.
Says that his own fucking trial.
Uh,
anyways,
I don't know.
I'm butchering it.
You got to see it.
The part we're fucking Jerry Lee Lewis considers driving over Liberace.
So there'd be quote,
one less piano play in motherfucker that he had to compete,
compete with.
Just imagine that animated.
That's I,
I,
it's,
it's incredible show,
incredible show.
And I resent every podcast listener for not telling me that it existed.
You probably did.
I just miss the emails.
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Bike mechanic from Vietnam.
Hey there,
mister Billie old rice ball.
I found your podcast last year and had been listening ever since.
I'm currently a bike mechanic at a local shop here in her noise,
Vietnamese born and raised.
Well,
I bet you get a ton of work.
Everybody rides bikes over there.
Right?
And I'm basing that on Hollywood movies that I've seen.
All right.
Um,
actually Tom Rhodes always does gigs over there and tells me how beautiful it
is.
And Tom Rhodes is going to be in Vietnam.
He was telling me and the next couple of months,
I believe,
at least this year,
I forget what the date is.
Uh,
all right.
I recently met the loveliest Colombian lady.
Oh,
they're beautiful,
beautiful women in the world at the shop.
And I am smitten.
I don't doubt it.
Problem is she's only gonna be here for one month before continuing to the next
destination.
On a world tour.
And what better time for you to get in there between those dyes?
Um,
I'm sorry.
Have a nice romance.
Uh,
she's covering from my fellow coworker who's on a trip of her own traveling
across the country.
I'm happy enough to have a month to spend with her.
I don't care if she's going to be gone forever afterwards.
I have no idea what to do though.
Always have been with women.
I've got no game.
I'm always a bit needy.
Oh,
that's a bad one.
Not,
no one wants to say it's easy.
That's easy.
You just,
you got to start bombing like a comedian.
Like the way a person learns how to become a comedian.
You just write some shit.
You don't know if it's funny,
you go up there,
you fucking,
you know,
lose on nine out of 10.
But You keep that one and you build off of that and then eventually you have an
act.
All right.
Needy.
He can't be needy.
I'm a bit needy and I'm constantly doubting myself.
Um,
all right,
well I'm,
I'm with you on the second one.
Uh,
and whether or not she likes me.
I know it's a good thing to do and I should stop thinking that way,
but it's not easy for me.
I guess I need some words of advice and encouragement.
A stank you very much and go hug yourself.
Um,
uh,
I would just,
you just,
you just gotta like
the thing about doubting yourself and being needy and all of that and just being
filled with doubt and no confidence is that is,
um,
that's one of those things where when you're really young,
the sooner you address that,
the better your life is going to be.
Okay.
Because that
you're so young at this point that it's not,
I don't think it's,
it just doesn't happen.
It's a mid senior,
like if you try to deal with it and your late thirties,
the way I did.
So,
uh,
and then you find out all this shit you were afraid of that you thought was,
I've got to walk up this fucking mountain.
It's was these,
it was like stepping up onto a curb.
So first of all,
in a good way,
who gives a fuck?
If you asked this checkout and she shoots you down,
who gives a fuck you,
all you have is a funny fucking story.
And in a,
in an experience asking a woman out,
especially if you think she's out of,
out of your league,
that's even better.
You know,
anything you want to do,
you got it.
You got to play with people that are better than you.
If you want to get better playing sports,
you know,
like I remember this guy was telling me about as far as like getting together,
if you play an instrument jamming with people,
buy when we were kids,
it goes always to be like a,
hey we should jam.
Well how long have you been playing?
I've been playing for years.
I've only been playing a year.
I can't play a,
you can be too good.
It's like,
no,
you should go play with them cause they're gonna they're gonna pull you up.
Alright,
so it's the same thing with this thing.
You've got this beautiful Colombian woman,
she's going to be leaving soon.
So first of all,
the fact that this going to be no relationship beyond this.
There's going to be no pressure.
So the level of fun that you guys can have is going to be ridiculous.
So,
um,
okay.
I would just start hitting on her personally.
Just make subtle comments.
Just tell us you whatever she's wearing and tell her she looks good.
She has got,
I don't know,
should I wear this?
I know you always feel you look good and everything.
Really.
Yeah,
I think you're beautiful.
Just like that and fuck all these fucking women.
Two of them.
Good.
Who,
who center at work?
Fuck off.
Okay.
He's a guy he ate at some point.
He has to get off the wall and try and make something happen.
Okay.
It'd be one thing if women hit on guys and we could sit there and be like,
don't talk about my pecs like that.
God stopped complimenting me.
Um,
I'm not saying to be a creep.
All right?
But you got to let her know that you like her.
So,
uh,
okay.
I,
that's what I would do.
I would just compliment her,
make her laugh.
Be just,
be in a good,
just be funny,
chill fucking person.
All right.
Don't be overly aggressive,
don't be fucking needy.
All of that Shit freaks him the fuck out.
Just freaks him out.
They run in the other fucking direction.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I dunno if you've got a sense of humor or whatever.
It seems like you do the way you wrote this shit and a lot of people that are
needy and n n doubt those cells are funny people.
Okay,
so I need to compliment her.
Be a little self deprecating about yourself.
Then she goes,
no,
I think he looked good and blah,
blah blah.
And then she takes a step in your direction and then just fucking go from there.
And then just one day,
just look at it.
Say,
hey listen,
I know you're only going to be here for like a month,
but I really like you.
I think you're beautiful and I'd love to go out with you.
Let's go hang out.
Let's go do something.
I'll fucking,
I'll had pile of shit over there.
I'll turn that into a bicycle,
puts you on the handlebars or drive around.
Go see a movie or some shit.
Who gives a fuck what she says.
I'll tell you what you,
if she says no,
that is going to hurt way less than for the rest of your fucking life.
Sitting there going,
you know what a fucking anybody trying to fucking ass that Colombian checkout.
Okay.
That,
that lasts a lifetime.
A woman shooting you down like all you gotta do get how long that lasts,
that lasts as long as however long it takes to call one of your friends to tell
him the funny story.
Back when I started off as a comedian,
I swear to God I was bombing so much that it got to the point while I was
bombing,
I was already thinking about calling Patrice and telling them the story and
listening to him laugh at me.
Cause it used to always make me feel better or Dane or Bobby or any of those
other guys that I started out with and like all the humiliation,
I was almost like,
oh,
good on bombing.
I have a funny story to tell those other guys and it stopped being like a
negative thing.
Um,
so there you go.
I don't want to fucking oversell you on this ship,
but a good for you.
You're young,
you're in a beautiful country and a beautiful woman's going to be there for a
month.
Fucking a,
you're supposed to have fun.
All right,
so there you go.
Good luck to you sir.
All right.
Selma and Louise.
I mentioned last,
uh,
last podcast that me and Nia sat down and watched that movie and how incredible
a movie that is.
How poignant it is.
Now.
You could almost look at a Thelma and Louise,
like it was warning all of these people now they've got these youtube fucking
cases,
um,
that they had fucking had enough and that they're the sick cause every,
it's every literally every like strain of different types of creepy guy or lying
or whatever the fuck you want to call it.
And uh,
held up really well.
And then I was talking about that Crystal Mcdonald,
who plays Darryl quit
that guy.
Um,
just blew me away.
All right.
He said,
Bill,
regarding your mention of filming Louise on the March 12th,
Monday morning podcast.
A couple of things I learned about that movie from the book off the cliff.
How the making of film in Louise Drove Hollywood to the edge by Becky Aikman
drove it to the edge.
I don't know about that.
Uh,
the movie was almost made with Jodie foster and Michelle Pfeiffer in the lead
roles.
Is that amazing?
After they cast it and then you try to picture new people in there and you like
that one to work,
you know,
both of them incredible actresses.
You like that?
Why?
Why the fuck would you put them in there?
A Crystal Mcdonald who played Delmas husband.
Darryl has been engaged to Gina Davis at one time.
Okay.
A few years before the movie.
Oh Wow.
He also nearly stole the movie by improvising a lot of his role,
much to the amusement of director Ridley Scott.
Yeah,
I thought he was,
if you watch Harvey Keitel,
he's literally just laughing
when watching the,
uh,
what's,
this guy's doing?
A three.
The role of hunky cowboy originally went to Stephen Baldwin.
I didn't know that.
Who backed out at the last second to be in backdraft.
That's understandable.
I'd probably get a bigger role.
Five actors were brought back to audition with Gina Davis for Brunettes and an
unknown blonde named Brad Pitt Davis loved pit and he ended up getting the job.
Years later,
Davis found herself on a plane seated next to George Clooney.
Clooney made a comment about Pitt stealing a role from him when they were both
getting started in the business.
Turns out it was the Thelma and Louise Park.
No Way.
I love this shit.
We should do more of this on the podcast.
George was one of the four brunettes and Davis had never known it.
Wow.
What the fuck airline is that?
It's definitely not southwest crew beak.
I can tell you that right now.
All right.
Also just saw the Ricky Gervais',
Netflix specials,
humanity in it.
He has a nice bit after the 40 minute mark about intolerance,
especially related to comedy.
There's another segment right after the one hour mark where he discusses rape
jokes and people's reaction to them would have crossed the border to see you in
Kitchener,
uh,
tonight.
But after all it is Saint Patrick's day and there are bar crawls and drinking
etiquettes to be observed.
Aaron go bra,
you Ella Vena,
you albino fucking Leprechaun.
I fucked that up.
That's Aaron go bra.
You Alab you albino Leprechaun.
Uh,
anyways,
oh,
you know something.
I actually learned a lot about Kitchener cause I was asking him,
I go,
what did you guys use to make here that just had that vibe and they all left.
And uh,
I guess that was the place where they used to make crown royal to Seagram's
family was from there.
And Joe Barton,
nick,
um,
who should be on their wall of fame has said,
he said he's thrown out at least 400 of those purple bags in his lifetime.
Um,
they also make,
um,
the best striper,
striper,
the best sniper rifles in the world where you can basically be deadly accurate
from two and a half miles away.
And I was joking about that,
like the power of that,
like how relaxed you could be,
you know what I mean?
You're two and a half miles away from the mercy you cell phones there.
So he just couldn't be like,
yeah,
I wasn't there.
Check out my cell phone.
You know,
all you do is put a silencer on the end of the fucking thing and you just start
talking to one of your friends and then you just look in two and a half miles
down the road at this mother is that son of a bitch right here.
You got the gun half disassembled by the time he fucking hits the guy and you go
perfect fucking murder.
I,
you know,
it's funny.
All these gun nuts are going to write in.
Oh actually they be able to trace the bullet and they would,
you know,
Redo the sheer numbers on the gun shot up,
joke.
It's a fucking joke.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
you know what's great about Saint Patrick's Day was,
I wasn't even aware there was Saint Patrick's day when it did the kitchen,
her gig and we drove all the way back and then we partied at this place called
the bill Hicks Bar and you're going to the bathroom.
They had all these quotes of uh,
you know,
Bill Hicks on the wall.
Those.
It was a bunch of standup comics hanging out there and we had a great time
because we reached out and we try to find a place where we could actually hang
out and drink some nonalcoholic beers.
And we want to thank everybody there at the,
uh,
sober bill Hicks Bar for letting us act like gentlemen.
Um,
all right,
Bill.
I'm a 20 year old and I lost my older girlfriend who has kids.
Ah,
congratulations.
This.
This is a fucking,
this is a problem.
Hey Bill,
I've been a fan for a while and I know you have plenty of advice in that shiny
head or you're
not saying any of you.
It's good or professional.
For the last four months I've really been beating myself up because I didn't,
I didn't stand up for myself and I let the most amazing girl I've ever met go
back to her ex because I didn't think I could support her and her two kids.
I've had many girlfriends before,
Dude,
you 20 before her.
And I've been sad about a breakup,
but not like this.
I was drinking heavily and taking pain pills do don't do that because I know I
can't have her back.
I don't know how to move forward from here.
I've gotten myself off the pills great.
And I've cut down on the drinking,
but I can't seem to feel anything for any other girl.
I just don't really have any drive without her.
What should I do now?
Thanks.
Even if you don't get around to this,
um,
first of all,
forgive yourself.
All right?
There's not a person out there,
all right?
That hasn't fucking fucked up a relationship unless you just marry the first
person that you're with.
You know,
like they used to do back in the turn of last century.
Hey,
I do.
I mean,
I fucked up like three before I found Nia just really fucked him up and thought
I'd never get past.
I mean,
you know,
like you do,
this is a great time for you,
okay?
Because you're,
what you're learning to do is pick yourself up off the mat.
Do you remember?
Were you ever see that George Foreman fight when he fights Ali?
And he goes down and decades later they asked him about being down on the canvas
and he said,
you know what?
You know what the truth is?
He goes,
I could have got up.
I just never been there before.
All right.
And after that,
look at him.
The guy came back when he was like in his forties and won the fucking
heavyweight title.
Um,
so look,
it's the first time you've been knocked on your ass like this and this is great.
You're going to learn something from it.
And uh,
you're single and you know what?
The fact that she can't feel anything about anybody else knew it was because
you're a good person.
You actually have feelings for this other person.
So what you do is you just fucking go out,
hang with your friends,
have a good time.
If you meet some chick asked,
she asked you what your deal is.
Say I just went through a bad breakup.
Blahblahblahblahblah and I swear to God,
they'll,
they'll want to cheer you up so much.
You probably get a fucking blow job out of it.
I'm telling you,
they love a fucking fixer upper.
They love a little sad god damn face.
Just say a fucked up a relationship and I'm heartbroken about it.
What's going on with you?
Okay.
As opposed to fucking,
you know,
leading them on and acting like you liked them and then they find out you're
hung up on some other girl.
That's when they get mad and fucking do to destruction of property,
not get prosecuted for it.
You know,
it's actually a commercial out right now with this woman's just breaking this
guy shit thrown it out the window.
Like that's totally fucking fine,
you know?
I don't understand that at all.
So that's what I would say.
Okay,
buddy.
I got to be honest with you.
Okay?
I know she's great and everything,
but she's older than you and she has kids.
That's a hell of a fucking thing to paratroop into.
All right.
Okay.
Just Sunday,
you're going to meet another one.
You're going to find the real fucking thing.
All right?
And you know,
this is not going to be,
oh,
can you support me in all my fucking kids that I had with somebody else?
Or I'm going to go back to that guy that sounds like a fucking country song yet,
Dude,
you don't need that shit.
You're going to find some fucking girl.
You're going to,
who knows,
a year from now,
two years from now,
three,
four years,
whatever.
You're going to find the fucking love of your life,
okay?
And you know what?
You're going to wish you dead someday during the time before your matter is
fucking went out and had a good time and bagged everything you possibly fucking
could,
but then fucking reason consensually with a condom there.
Did I say it right?
Go out and have a great fucking time.
Enjoy your fucking life.
Because someday you're going to make the girl your dreams,
the person you're supposed to be with.
All right?
And you're going to get married and you're going to have a kid.
And then even though you love all of them and everything,
you know your podcast is going to be late cause you gotta go.
You gotta go down to the east of buddy,
you got to do what?
You can't miss that shit and all your free time is going to be gone.
It's not going to be a bad thing because you're going to love the kids so much.
However you are going to think back to a lot of the free time he had thick of
Jesus Christ.
Why the fuck didn't I do this and that?
So all this woman did was give you a great opportunity to go out and fucking
enjoy yourself.
All right?
And when nobody's looking,
put your face in the pillow and fucking cry it out of you.
Do it every day.
That's what they do.
You got to,
you got to cry yourself.
They never tell guys to do that,
right?
Cry Yourself into forgive yourself and all of that shit.
In the meantime,
have a great fucking time.
All right,
go get a kegerator.
Watch a little march madness.
Go to the gym,
get in great shape.
There's all kinds of positive things you can do.
All right,
wife cheated on me night before our wedding.
Oh boy.
The next one is fucked.
My roommate's sister,
Jesus Christ.
Fucking an said,
listen to this podcast.
Um,
it's almost like I attract them with my own ignorance.
All right.
Wife cheated on me night before our wedding.
Dear Billy hotlips,
my wife and I have been happily married for 13 years.
We live in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
Well,
not to get selfish,
share with your extremely painful story,
but I'm going to be in,
I'm going to be at the Brady theater and Tulsa,
Oklahoma coming in the next few months.
Okay.
All right.
Where are we met at the University of,
I'm not gonna say the university,
Kate.
That we have two children ages 10 and seven.
Okay.
And have a really comfortable life together.
The other night it took my wife out for a date night dinner and bowling.
The bowling sounds lame,
but remember it's Tulsa.
Do Bowling is the shit
you get in the league.
It's fucking awesome.
Anyways,
my wife and I went up to the bar at the bowling alley and when the bartenders
saw her,
he gave her a weird looks sorta like cabin.
I met you before.
Okay.
After taking our order.
He came back with drinks and said,
enjoy Mitzi.
I was shocked when he knew her name and I gave my wife a puzzled look.
We took the drinks and went back to our lane and I asked her how he could know
her name.
She said she has no idea and checked her shirt as if for some reason she was
wearing a name tag.
Yeah.
After a few minutes when she couldn't think of an excuse or a lie,
she dropped a bomb on me.
She told me that he was the bartender from the hotel where we had our wedding
reception.
She said the night before our wedding,
after our rehearsal dinner,
her and her bridesmaids went to the hotel to sleep and stopped at the lobby bar
for a couple of drinks.
Everyone then went up to bed,
but my wife,
I are good friends,
but Paul,
everyone over to Belmont,
but my wife snuck down to go talk to the bartender.
Oh wait a minute.
My apologies to her friends.
She told him that she's getting married tomorrow,
but once one more night with another man before giving herself to me.
So she took him up to the honeymoon suite and had sex with them,
which by the way is the same bed that we consummated our marriage and the next
night.
Oh God.
Yeah.
She told me she was never going to tell me because it meant nothing more than
her wanting to enter a single life with a bang,
not a whimper.
Literally a bank.
She claims she has never had doubts about us and that she's sorry that I found
out,
but she doesn't regret the cheating because it assures her that she had found
the guy.
Okay.
Who she wants to be forever.
Yeah,
buddy.
You try the same thing and then tell her that hey,
it meant nothing.
And when I was banging her I was like,
you know I,
yeah.
Yay.
And with the right broad,
after hearing this,
I asked if she could get cheated since we've been married and she said no,
which I believe we left the bowling alley and drove home in bitters.
Silence.
I've not spoken to her.
And about a week now other than when it pertains to the kids and other important
matters,
she's been sleeping in the guest room because she knows I don't want to be
around her.
However,
I know I need to confront her about this,
but I am unsure how to go about it.
I think the only scenarios are divorced or basically accepting and forgiving,
neither of which I want to do at this moment.
What she's,
you're fucking right.
I'm not telling any of my family or friends about this because I'm embarrassed.
So I'm hoping you can give advice,
love the podcast and go fuck yourself.
I tell her exactly what you just told me.
Okay.
Just say that the only two possible scenarios here or divorce or me accepting
and forgiving,
but I'm not ready to do either one at this moment.
Okay.
And you're going to have to accept that and my mood around you because of your
actions.
All right?
And by the way,
I'm not telling any of my family and friends about this because I'm so
embarrassed.
Okay.
And um,
then I would recommend going to some sort of couple's therapy.
Yeah.
Because that is a mind fuck beyond,
um,
any of my bar room fucking advice.
But uh,
you seem pretty well emotionally where you know exactly what you're feeling and
why you're feeling it.
I would just communicate it to her.
MMM.
And she better not Polish shit of like,
so he's just not going to talk to me from make it about herself.
MMM.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I think the only way,
how do you stay?
I mean you gotta stay cause the kids are there,
which is such a fucking situation.
And then,
um,
okay.
All right.
The positive side is she actually fucking owned up to it.
Negative.
She waited 13 years and two kids.
All right,
let's not do the positive and negative because I feel like once this is going to
be like a fucking bad super bowl here,
um,
yeah,
I dunno.
What is the solution you get to fuck somebody?
Um,
I don't know.
And it sounds to me like you didn't even want to do that,
so that's not going to be a fucking solution.
I Dunno.
I would get professional help when you're ready to sit down and talk about it.
Uh,
okay.
Listen,
it'd be one thing if you were fucking early on in your goddamn relationship,
but you were getting married the next day and then fucked in the old guy.
You don't that in literally that bed.
I had to be honest with you,
man.
That's pretty hardcore.
That's like guy level piece of shit behavior.
Um,
although women are totally capable of it,
that's just that,
that's not their ml because they're so good at being pieces of shit that
everybody thinks they're not.
We're guys,
we just constantly get caught with their fucking pants down.
Oh,
you shared,
you're going to be home later.
That's your fucking excuse.
Well,
I mean,
aren't you also being dishonest?
All
right.
Fucked my roommate's sister.
Oh boy.
All right,
dear Billy barnacles fucked my roommate's sister and I now need your help.
My roommates,
since it's the only way I can get through these because he's just so fucking
sad.
My roommate's sister was in town this weekend while he was at old town.
Uh,
she was going to the bars with some friends and crashing on a brother's bed,
my place or what have you.
She invited me out with her and I said,
fuck yeah.
Oh,
I'm paraphrasing.
You know,
she is pretty much our same age,
mid twenties,
as I hung out with a lot of our,
with,
you know,
and how it has hung out a lot with our group of friends that I've known her for
five years now.
And consider a friend outside of just my friend's sister is how I justify what
the fuck I did at the end of this ladder.
Uh,
so I figured what the hell,
maybe she could be a good wing man.
I could hit it off with what was one of her friends.
Unfortunately that wasn't what happened.
I ain't near,
just walked in.
Nia,
this guy just found out
he went,
he was at a bowling alleys in a bowling league with his wife or whatever.
Then there are balling.
Can I just ask the question,
was that your attempted a southern accent or what was that?
That you were just doing?
Oh,
it's because these are so sad.
I just have to do it in a silly accident because I want to hear it.
Was that a bad accent?
Yeah.
No,
it isn't.
It's a funny accent.
Okay.
I mean,
yeah.
Funny.
I'm not trying to like be like legitimately,
oh Jesus fucking Christ.
I came and making fun of you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did high
criticism.
It never ends.
Let's a,
that's your idea of a,
yeah.
Yeah.
I'm giving you shit.
Okay.
I just seem like I'm in the podcast.
Why are you being so sun symbol?
Because it sounded like you were serious.
Oh,
see,
now you're on Instagram.
You're going to get all like weird about stuff,
man.
I don't even know that.
I tell you right now,
I can't even,
I don't even understand Instagram,
what we were at all the whores.
What were all the Instagram whore is all I get is just shit from a people that I
know it.
Do you want to be following Instagram models?
I want to see him.
Well,
I'm sure after this people will send you loads of land.
you can't have the ones you look at.
Who do I give these shoes?
Radio,
shoot all of those tits hanging out.
Oh.
Um,
so this,
he's out bowling
is Tanea is your fucking ice coffee big enough for you?
It's a smoothie and it's this,
this is a regular size.
I love you all.
You guys who drink smoothies to lose weight.
It's like a giant chocolate shake.
I'm not,
this is not obviously to lose weight,
I just want,
I wanted a nice natural fucking drag.
Do we need to start again?
I guess I,
we're getting off on the wrong.
So this fucking guy goes out to bowl a bowl and I've been married 13 years.
He's got two kids,
like a 10 year old and a fucking seven or eight year old or something like that.
Right?
So they're Bolin and I go up to get some drinks and said when they went up there
that the bartender kind of gave his wife a weird look.
And then when he gave the drinks to her,
he said,
hey,
have a good night.
Mitzi,
like newer name.
So they go back over and he goes,
how the fuck did he know your name?
And she acted dumbfounded to the point of actually pretending to look for a name
on a shirt.
I don't know.
And then she just couldn't come up with a good line.
She finally just said the night before their wedding,
she banged the gay.
Oh,
but hasn't bagged anyone since she goes,
oh,
she said her and her friends were downstairs in the hotel lobby drinking.
They all went to bed and a night she snuck down and told the bartender she
wanted one last bang,
literally before she got married and went up to the honeymoon suite where they
consummated their marriage the next night and fuck that guy in that bed.
Oh Ooh,
Mitzi,
you are a dirty dog.
And then claimed that she never did anything like that again.
I mean that's pretty reptilian cold blooded behavior.
Yeah.
And are like,
what's the fucking bartender?
Daylight and like keep it on the fucking low man.
Like what?
Yeah,
he's an asshole.
Hey Go Mitzi.
And you know,
and you know he saw the wedding rings.
Like he cannot be cool.
Like he just had to be like a guy.
Wow.
So what is he asking?
What do I do?
Yeah,
cause she's not sleeping in the thing.
And he said the only solution is divorced or I forgive her sleeping in the thing
in the bedroom when she's sleeping.
Yeah.
No,
he hasn't talked to her in a week other than dealing with shit that they have to
talk about what?
Just the kids because he's not ready to and he's saying that the,
either they get fucking divorced or he forgives her,
but he hasn't told them he was friends and family because he's so embarrassed.
I I understand that.
Yeah.
I mean
you made this whole life.
Were there,
you have kids with her.
I don't know.
Is that really a deal breaker?
That's the thing though.
Is she still like messing around?
That's the thing.
The trust is broken.
So how do you repair the trust couple's therapy?
Yeah,
that's the only way.
I mean is she interested in like,
may she,
was she apologizing profusely?
Was she like,
I'm so ashamed.
Like I should never have done it.
It was wrong.
You know,
I love you so much.
Like I love our family.
Like,
I'll do anything to like make this better.
Cause that's,
that's a hell of a thing to,
to do the night before your marriage.
You're getting married in the bed that you then fuck your husband and you
believe that she's never done it again.
I don't know.
I don't,
I believe it cause I feel like women can do that.
Like do that.
Do you see what I'm saying?
How good they are at being pieces of shit.
They all cover each other.
I think that women can do that.
Guys can't do that.
But we can do that.
Yeah.
All right.
Get Out.
You're kicking me out.
I'm kicking you out.
I'm not saying that guys can't do that,
but yeah,
I feel like she's capable of light.
Why would you say that women can do that?
Because I'm talking about women.
So why,
why wouldn't you say that?
Well I feel it.
Some people can do that cause I don't have to use your language to get like my
point across.
But you just sorta,
they made just about women though.
I just,
interesting.
I'm cross examining you right now.
It's kind of fun,
but you try to worm your way out of this bullshit trying to warm their way.
I have anything wriggle.
Yeah,
keep drinking your fucking drink there.
So my roommate's sister was in town this weekend while he was out of town.
She was going to the bars,
uh,
with some,
France and crashing on a brother's bed and the place.
She invited me out with her and I said,
sure.
I figured she make a heck of a wing man and I could hit it off with one of her
friends.
Unfortunately that wasn't what happened.
Anyways,
we came back to my apartment where she was going to stay in her brother's bed
for,
I knew it.
One thing led to another and I was banging her life for her.
Nailed what I was under.
The clothes fly off and she bends over.
It started with some making out and she was the one who said,
let's go to your bed before you start thinking this is going to turn into the
wrong side of a me too story.
Hilarious.
That even puts that in there.
I that sounded all cash tag me too.
All right.
In the morning we both regretted it and she said it would probably be best not
to tell my roommate and her brother about the incident.
Unfortunately,
she was able to leave and go back to her place five hours away.
Well,
I have to see the guy every single day.
Oh,
okay.
I also did it with no condom,
like a drunken idiot,
so I've been freaking out about STDs and pregnancy even though I'm 99% sure I
didn't finish and made her get plan B the next night.
I'm pretty sure.
Excellent.
Careful.
He's probably an accountant major.
I'm pretty sure she'll never tell him,
but I'm kind of a pussy and feel like I,
I'll be plagued with guilt every time I hang out with the guy.
What should I do?
I'm sort of panicking and have a weight on my chest for the last week.
Should I suck it up and go to the grave with this?
I told a guy,
a couple of friends about this,
to get it up by conscious and now I'm afraid one of them might let it slow.
Dude,
you don't do that.
Let it slip one of these nights while we're all out drinking,
should I get ahead of the story and just tell him and suffer the consequences?
Or maybe I should stop being con and worry about people with actual problems.
I Dunno.
Glad.
Uh,
you're okay.
Well,
I,
I would say this,
um,
you're like that guy that commits a fucking crime with somebody else and then
you're the guy they have to whack because you're going to flip.
And what you basically did was you flipped on yourself and you ratted yourself
out to two other fucking people.
All right.
So,
um,
in the swirl of trash,
that's now going to happen,
I bet for upwards of 10 years or maybe never.
Um,
if you do something like that and you both agree to keep your fucking mouth
shut,
that's what she should have done because this isn't just about you.
It's also about his relationship with his sister.
All right.
So I don't get both adults.
It was consensual.
You didn't want it to happen.
It happened then you both said that was a fucking mistake.
Nobody's married here.
There's no kid involved.
I wouldn't have said Shit.
Yeah,
I think he should just keep a trap shut and just move on with your life.
Yeah.
And you also have to go kill your two friends.
You never watched those JFK conspiracies.
Um,
you tell the other two guys cause he just felt so guilty about it and yes,
the telltale heart,
it's up.
This is ball bag dick throbbing underneath.
It's really not.
It's not that big of a deal.
Yeah.
And she did turn out to be pregnant and kept it.
Yes,
of course you'd have to come clean,
but you're even say go through with an abortion without,
he doesn't need to know.
No,
I wasn't going to say that.
What are you talking about?
As you said,
if she got pregnant,
she got pregnant and decided to keep it.
Then you say something but she,
she got pregnant and didn't want to keep it.
You don't say shit.
You know what I'm saying?
But she took the plan B.
So it's just like,
it's fine.
This feels like a fast times at Ridgemont high.
I'm just picturing judge Reinhold at big blue car.
I know,
but she didn't get an abortion and she took a plan B.
So it's,
it's,
it's fine sir.
Do you sell stereos?
Um,
that's for old people would get that joke.
She banged that goes,
sold the stairs.
She's got to be some baddies bay tonight.
Really creepy song choice.
Um,
only bangs are right on that fucking bench.
Yeah.
She's such a cutie pie that when she was that age,
Jennifer,
Jason Leigh,
I liked that movie.
Ageism too.
She's not a cutie pie now.
Now she's a beautiful woman.
Now that she was a cutie pie when she was a younger mm hmm.
When we return,
there's nothing there for you to dig out this.
And I think,
well that's,
well that's the age we live in.
If there is nothing your,
if there's something there or there's nothing there,
you're still going to be punished.
Oh,
you look extra pretty today.
What'd you do?
Since I left,
I dunno.
You fucking a guy at a bowling alley.
Yup.
I ain't going to be like,
I ain't doing,
Mitzi
is going to be my code name.
Now,
if I do step out on you,
I'm going by Mitzi.
You know what?
I'm so old.
That guy be doing me a favor.
Oh,
Phoebe doesn't happen in a Mandy Moore Claremont top.
I'm too old.
You're just as much of a stallion.
The truth hurts.
I tell you,
I'd rather take a nap at this point.
No,
you would not.
I would know you.
You'd rather take a nap then bang me.
Oh No.
We got to see how that works.
Everybody.
That's exactly how it's done.
It's son of a man.
All right.
That's it.
That's the best lesson I could have taught anybody.
All right.
Have a great fucking week.
Your consult.
Talk to you on Thursday.